as you pointed out i'm going to
hold up these books so this is the new
book
beyond order
and it does concentrate on pathologies
of structure and the previous book which
is 12 rules for life and antidote to
chaos
and
the the underlying presupposition there
is that in our phenomenological
landscape so that's the world as we
experience it complete with emotions and
motivations and dreams and
so the full range of human experience
including the subjective and the
objective let's say
can broadly be broken into two domains
and one is the domain of things that are
beyond our grasp and reach and that's
the unknown
the unknown emerges when the unknown
emerges you tend to experience anxiety
and then there's the the known and i
define the known very specifically and
and very carefully
the known is the place you are
when what you're doing presult produces
the results you want and i say want
because that brings motivation and
emotion into the game so
you're motivated to pursue something
you pursue it and what you want happens
not only do you get what you want but
you get validation for the structure
that governs your perceptions and your
actions now if you
you know imagine that you're um you know
you're lonely
and you approach a young woman in a in a
social situation
attempting to make some contact with her
um you you want to alleviate your
loneliness and so you hope you make a
good impression and you tell a joke
let's say in a relatively awkward manner
and you get rebuffed
then
you feel you you
you're no longer where you control
you're no longer where you exercise
control and that brings up all sorts of
specters and immediately it's like well
why were you rebuffed well maybe all
women are uh to be despised that's one
theory maybe there's something deeply
wrong with you maybe you're having an
off day maybe it wasn't a very good joke
and so when you don't get what you want
then a landscape of question emerge
questions emerge and those questions can
resonate through different levels of
your identity from the trivial oh i told
the joke wrong to the profound there's
nothing desirable about me and i'll be
alone for the rest of my life now you
asked about identity and i used the
example of a child's game but i could go
through an identity and so i do this
particularly in maps of meaning and so
for example let's say i'm sitting typing
okay we could decompose my identity so
at the highest level of resolution i'm
moving my fingers
and so that could be my identity i'm the
thing that moves its fingers
and then
slightly at a slightly broader level
than that i'm typing words
and at a broader level i'm typing
phrases and thinking them up and then
sentences
and then paragraphs
and then chapters and then let's say
full papers or books that that's that's
a productive unit so i'm the author of a
book or the author of a paper that's an
identity but then that's nested inside
for me it would be nested inside being a
clinical psychologist being a professor
being a good citizen
and then that's nested in some inside
something that's even broader than that
and i would say that that's nested
inside
a cultural heroism and i don't mean that
specific to me i mean that for everyone
that's the outermost level whether
you're playing out the role of hero or
adversary say
that's that's the highest possible level
of identity that's the level at which
fundamental morality is adjudicated and
there isn't really anything beyond
outside that is it's beyond us it's the
transcendent itself and you're all of
those at
any one time
you're all of those levels of identity
but those are all practical right so
those are the roles that you're playing
in the world all of those are
a consequence of
who you are but in interplay like in
this situation with the child
all of that's negotiated with other
people
and so if you have a functional identity
you see if you have a functional
identity
when you act it out in the world
then you get what you want and need
and if an identity doesn't do that well
then you should
you either retool or your identity
or you retool the world
your conception of the world
well
if you're retooling your conception of
the world then you're retooling yourself
no you can actually i mean what a
revolutionary does is try to bring the
world into alignment with literally
yes literally well and we all do that to
some degree because we are practical
engineers you know i mean
not only do we
perceive the world
but we also
interact with it so that it does
manifest itself in accordance with our
desires there's limits obviously to how
far you can go or how far you should go
with that
you know and
um what are the limits well there's
practical limits nature won't do what
you want it to unless you're
very sophisticated in your
in your application of your knowledge
and other people will object
so
now you might say well you should forge
forward regardless of their objection
and
you know there are circumstances under
which that's true
but
generally speaking that's not a very
good idea it certainly doesn't make you
popular as a child and so that brings up
one other issue i would also say and
this i developed this idea quite a bit
in
the new book
you go from egocentrism as a child you
have to go through this period where
you're socialized as a child and
adolescent and that really means that
you allow your identity to be molded and
shaped by the group
and you know you think about how
important peers friends and peers are to
children and adolescents
you know your mother will say when
you're a teenager well if johnny jumped
off the bridge would you too
and you say well no but the real answer
is well probably if all your friends are
there taunting you you would in fact
jump off the bridge and not only that
generally speaking you should
because
it's your
duty
it's your developmental duty as a child
and a teenager
to
take your
your isolated self and turn it into us a
functioning social unit
now
you could say well do you peterson wants
everybody to be a functional social unit
a robot you know a cog in the wheel
and i would say well that that isn't
where development stops
it has to go through that period before
you can emerge as a as a genuine
individual which means you have to know
the rules of the game before you can
break them
but
not being able to abide by the rules is
not anything like being a genuine
creative individual those are not the
same thing and there's plenty of attempt
to confuse the two things because it's
much better if you can't follow the
rules
to view yourself as a uh
avant-garde revolutionary than as a
failure
and it's not like i don't know that
that social molding crushes
obviously it crushes and everyone feels
that these are existential problems
everyone deals with the tyranny of
culture
and the fact that
it does want you to be a certain way and
not other ways and those ways might not
be in keeping with your with your the
deepest elements of your nature well
tough luck for you you have because
you're also the beneficiary of culture
and so you have to offer it your pound
of flesh now you shouldn't do that at
the expense of your soul but you
shouldn't stay an immature child other
either
and so this notion of identity that
we're being fed is very very
it's very thin what are we being fed be
very specific
well there is the idea for example that
your identity is whatever you say it is
and that everyone else has to go along
with that
no
that isn't how it works partly because
no one even knows how to go along with
it
like let's say just for example that
you're a gender non-binary
okay
what am i supposed to do
about that
man i don't know i hardly know what to
do if the rules are already there so
let's say
i grow up i want to being a heterosexual
male
i want to find a woman
fall in love with her
raise a family
have children have grandchildren that's
a game i know the rules to it not well
because everyone's a failure at that you
know it's very difficult but at least
you kind of know what the
goal is and so does the person you're
with
well you leap out of that which is
already terribly difficult you leap out
of that into completely unknown
territory saying um
uh
that i'm
presenting yourself as something other
than those categories leaves everyone
around you and you
completely bereft of direction
let me put it in any words that i get
from
your material so what i heard you just
say tell me if i'm wrong is part of the
negotiation that we do from the time we
are little kids and figuring out that
play we're up on the bridge we jump
maybe because we want to you know fit in
with our peer group
um
it there is a sense of order to that now
you've been very careful and it would
drive me crazy if people respond to this
interview as if you have not already
illustrated that it is the balance
between two opposing forces but so we
need enough order so that somebody can
find their way through the world and
that many i think a big part of the
reason that your work has resonated so
profoundly with people is there excuse
me they are left in a world where they
don't know how to
move forward
in a way that serves them spiritually
practically as well for sure and so hey
everybody both of those both of those
practically shades into spiritually as
you move up into the broader reaches of
identity
you know and look this this see one of
the things i really laid this out in
maps of meaning
it took me a long time to understand
that belief regulated emotion
so what happens is that if you act out
your identity if you act out your
beliefs in the world and
what you want doesn't happen
what happens is that your body defaults
into emergency preparation for action
and the reason for that is you've
wandered too far away from the campfire
and now you're in the forest and maybe
you're naked
and so what do you do then and the
answer is well you don't know what to do
so what do you do when you don't want
know what to do and the answer is you
prepare to do everything and the problem
with that is that it's unbelievably
draining psychophysiologically
like it hurts you
and there's there's an immense
physiological literature detailing
the the cost of of of exactly that kind
of response
and so people need people and animals
they people stay where
what they do has the results they want
that's partly why you want to be around
people who share your cultural
presuppositions
is because you know that for example
even in small ways
let's say you're a country music
aficionado
and you're hanging around with your
cowboy hatted buddies and you throw on a
tape and everyone says great tunes man
and you you know you're happy about that
but you know
you throw on a piece by tchaikowski and
you're
you're in a different subculture and who
the hell are you
and people who the people in your group
will say man who listens to music like
that and like that's a trivial example
in some sense but i believe it's one
that everyone can resonate to
we like we it's very hard on us not to
be where
we know what
we know that what we want is going to
happen we hate that
we hate that and no wonder
so and then you know there are there are
varying degrees of that obviously you
can really be where you don't know
what's going to happen or you can only
be there to some degree
but
by and large
by and large we're conservative
creatures even if we're liberal and
temperament there's not we can't
tolerate that much uncertainty
and
you might ask well why and the answer is
well because you can be hurt
pain you can be damaged you can become
intolerably anxious and you can die
so it's no wonder you're sensitive we're
very sensitive to negative emotion
and so our identities
rate functional identity regulates your
emotion why beyond order what is the
genesis of that title how did you arrive
at that title
as far as i can tell
in the world of value
so let's think about value for a minute
if you move towards something you value
it
otherwise you would move towards it you
there's an old joke about the chicken is
why did the chicken cross the road
and the answer to that is well he
thought the other side was better
well that's that's the case you know and
in order
we need a gradient of value to organize
our action
and what you have to prioritize because
you can't do everything at once and so
you do the thing that's most important
right now now and that means you're in a
world of importance
and that's a value that that's a value
world and the value world as far as i
can tell has two broad components the
taoists talked about it as yin and yang
and broadly speaking its order and chaos
and order tends to be represented with
masculine symbols and chaos tends to be
represented for feminine with feminine
symbols that doesn't mean order is male
and chaos is
female
and you know i've been pilloried for
this even though it's hardly my
proposition but
that
the idea of the
patriarchy is a symbolic
it's it's use of masculine symbolism to
represent order
so
anyways
order is where what happens
order is you're in order when
what you want to happen happens when you
act
and so that's reassuring because not
only do you get what you want but the
fact that you get what you want
indicates that your theory about how to
get what you want is true
and every time you fail you don't get
what you want but you also
undermine the validity of the theory
that you're using to organize your
perceptions and your actions that's
partly why people don't like to fail
because you don't know how far back that
can
uh echo how far down your hierarchy of
presuppositions that can echo if you're
clinically depressed every minor failure
means you're worthless human being
and you never know when a failure is
going to demonstrate that you know it
can
in any case
there's chaos and order there are the
two great domains and
you have to contend with chaos because
too much of it overwhelms you you drown
in it
it's the flood
and that happens when your life gets
beyond you
and you're somewhere where no matter
what you do nothing you want happens
it's a domain of terror and pain now
it's also a domain of unlimited
possibility
because outside of what you know is
everything you don't know
and there's untold riches to be gathered
from the domain of everything you don't
know but that doesn't mean it
it still needs to be managed it's
dangerous now the domain of order is the
same way it's like
if if order becomes too extreme then
everything becomes cramped it becomes
totalitarian and then that starts to
pathologize that's the dying king the
king who's dying for lack of the water
of life is the old tyrant who can no
longer see beyond his own
presuppositions
and so my first book concentrated more
on
pathologies of chaos
and and the second book more on
pathologies of order
and
they're they're a matched set in in that
regarding so far as i was successful at
doing that and you know the liberal
types
they're very sensitive to pathologies of
order
and the conservative types are very
sensitive to pathologies of chaos
but they're both right it's just there's
no final solution to that problem
you're stuck with it it's an existential
uh
it's an eternal existential concern
that's why mythological language is
standard across people is no matter who
you are no matter when you live you
always have to deal with the fact that
some things escape your competence
and no matter where you are no matter
who you are you have to
you have to adapt to the fact of the
existence of a value structure that's
shared across a social group
it's the fundamentals so those are
fundamental constituent elements of
human experience
and we have symbols for them
and we all understand the symbols so for
example in pinocchio this is i'm not
going to go into this because it's too
complicated but
no one balks at a puppet going to the
bottom of the ocean and being swallowed
by a whale
why
it makes no sense
there's nothing about that that makes
sense
right it's not it's obviously not an
empirical description of the objective
world but it's so
clearly
real that a four-year-old can
follow it
it's a mystery
you know the whale breathes fire in
pinocchio
it's a dragon
and
why why is that well we face dragons
forever that's what a human being is
it's a creature that faces the dragon
the dragon can burn you to a crisp but
it has
it has what you need that's the world
it'll burn you up but it has what you
need
and so then the question is how do you
stop from getting burned up and get what
you need and the answer to that is that
you mold yourself into the hero
and that's a religious story
and you say well is it true and the
answer to that is it depends on what you
mean by true
and you know that's a weasel answer in
some ways but it's not
it's because it's such a deep question
that it can't be put forth without
discussing the definition of true
so it's as deep a question as what is
true
now you know it could be that
the
i would say that part of the cultural
war
is a criticism of the motif of the hero
that's darada's fellow ghost centrism
western culture is fellow go-centric i
would say human culture his fellow fell
logo centric i think derek it was wrong
about that it's human culture
it's it's man so to speak against nature
although sometimes it's man against
culture and sometimes it's man against
man
it's man against nature and we triumph
as the hero and maybe that story isn't
true or isn't correct
but it that's us
and if it isn't correct well then
we're a evolutionary abortion
because that's who we are
and i would say well before you throw it
aside maybe you should try it
you don't have a better option anyways
and a lot and
there there are
what does it mean to try it
mostly i would say it means
it means two things it means to
practice love
and that means
assume that things are valuable and act
according to that assumption
and it requires truth which is
don't
say what you know to be untrue
and you know when i tried to unpack
the first sentence of genesis
in the context of the broader biblical
narrative
what appears to be happening is that
there's a proposition that god is guided
by love and uses truth to create
it's something like that
and
maybe love is something like the wish
that all being would flourish
there isn't a better story than that
what effect do you hope your
new book to have
know that's that might seem like a lazy
question but i'm going to keep it broad
i'd just be interested to hear
your thoughts
what would what would be success a
successful effect
for this book
looking back 12 months from now 24
months from now well i would like it
would be lovely if it had the same
effect on people as the last book
appeared to have
you know i mean
it's comforting to me to
read through my youtube comments
oddly enough because that isn't
generally a place people would go for
comfort
you know
untold numbers of people
have said to me in person but
publicly in in that way
that
they put their lives together at least
in some ways
and you talked about victor frankel
you know when i wrote maps of meaning i
said well i was interested in
malevolence
i was deeply affected by the accounts
i'd read of what happened in the second
world war and
in germany and what happened in soviet
union and in china these horror shows
that characterized the 20th century
constrain malevolence
and so
if you study malevolence you start to
understand what the opposite of that is
the opposite of malevolence is something
like the hero's journey
you know and it's it's easy to be
cynical about that but
well it's not that easy because if
you're cynical about that then you
undermine your own life
and everyone knows this this is the
other thing that's so interesting
everyone knows this
you never teach someone you love to lie
you're always appalled if you have a son
or daughter
you're always appalled if they don't
tell the truth
you know in the deepest
part of your heart
that if you don't tell the truth
the world falls apart
and that's actually true
let's dive into the book because
actually so many of the things that
we're talking about now are sort of part
and parcel to all of the chapters here
so so chapter one and what i really
liked about this also is the way you
organized it
the the the new topics because one of
the questions we would get often in the
in the q a that you would get is oh was
there a was there a 13th rule that you
couldn't get in the book and you
actually mentioned this in the book that
you had you had what about 46 other was
it 46 42 42 you had 40 yeah the same as
douglas adams answer to the universe
life the universe and everything 42
rules which was actually a coincidence
but i thought it was comical in the
aftermath there's 42 rules so now i've
written about 20 i've written essays
about on 24 of them how did when you got
to 42 how long did you give it before
you said okay 42 is enough because i
know you you're pretty methodical
i just did it in an afternoon the
original list of rules i was playing on
quora
um
i i wrote about 40 answers for quora
something like that and i really haven't
partaken in that forum
for a long time now
um i was investigating it and
some kid had asked
what what you need to know in order to
lead a good life or what's most
important to know something like that
and i thought well i'll you know take a
crack at answering this and i made this
list of 42 rules and
it got very popular on quora much more
popular
typical pareto distribution like that
one answer got more views than all of my
other answers put together
and so i thought that was kind of
interesting you know i touched something
for some reason
and out of that when i was asked by an
agent who contacted me sally harding
of
of cook agency
she asked me if i was interested in
writing something more popular and i
knew that those rules
had found an audience so that seemed to
me to be a place to dive in
so anyways i've only written about 24 of
them you know in the two books there
have them both here you can see how
they're how they're
structured
one's white and the others black they
make a match set you can read each of
them independently and one concentrates
the first one
an antidote to chaos 12 rules
for life and antidote to chaos does
concentrate on
the consequences of excess uncertainty
and the second book concentrates more on
an excess of
of of order both of those are
fundamental existential dangers as far
as i'm concerned and
in this universe of value in the world
of value there are two major domains and
one domain is the domain of order
and you can technically define it the
domain of order is where you find
yourself
when what you're doing
produces the results you want
and that's that's a really tight
formulation because
um it gives you a particular idea of
what a of what a place and time is
the place and time you occupy is
at any given moment is the place and
time that's defined by your current goal
and
you have a map of value that guides you
through the the actions that are
necessary in that domain and if the
result is what you want which brings
motivation and emotion into the picture
then
while you get what you need or want but
you also validate your theory of
existence because it's good enough to
produce the results that you desire and
it given that you're fallible and that
you don't know everything
you have to use proximal
you have to use proximal truths
and so something is it's a pragmatic
it's it's a form of philosophical
pragmatism
you're you if you make a bridge and it
stands up then you know how to make a
bridge why because
the bridge stood up now maybe you over
built it you could have built it more
elegantly but
it's sufficiently true so that the
bridge functions and we're like that
we're like engineers we're cobbling
together solutions all the time and as
long as those solutions work we assume
that we're right
well that's that's the domain of order
the domain of chaos emerges when you lay
out a plan and into action and something
other than what you wanted emerges and
sometimes that can be a catastrophe an
absolute catastrophe and
your your
brain our psychophysiological
uh our psychophysiology is actually
adapted to those two domains
um
when something unexpected happens
all sorts of emotions and motivations
break loose fight and flight among them
anger among them gets disinhibited
because when you don't know what's
happening
you have to prepare for everything so
you get anxious and then you hyper
prepare which is extremely stressful and
so the domain of chaos is extremely
stressful
in small doses it's exhilarating
and that's because
well where you don't when you're where
you don't know what's happening you have
the opportunity to learn
and to expand your map
and so there's always an interplay
between the domain of chaos and the
domain of order but they can each
pathologize and the pathologies of
uncertainty are more associated with
anxiety and nihilism and depression and
whereas the pathologies of order are
more totalitarian
and then i would say as well
the liberals liberal types the more
left-leaning types are quite sensitive
to
pathologies of
order they don't like them they're that
that's the patriarchy the patriarchy is
the pathology of order and it's
symbolically masculine something i've
been you know uh taken to task for
claiming but
the patriarchy itself the idea of the
patriarchy itself is a symbol
the patriarch is a symbol that's why it
has such power and it's a symbol that
refers to the domain of order
now the domain of order is protective as
well as oppressive but when it
degenerates it becomes oppressive
and i would say it degenerates when it's
based on power rather than competence
but it can be based on competence
you know the the marxist critics and
then and and
the politically correct types
they
insist that every element of the
patriarchy is only a consequence of the
imposition of order forceful imposition
of order it's all power well no
no it's not when it degenerates that's
true
because and you can tell that because
the thing is the domain of order will be
upheld by those who inhabit it if it's
functional
if you have to use force that's already
an indication that it's become
pathological
because people aren't playing
voluntarily
so so would you say we're in a
degenerative
cycle right now that the cycle seems
more degenerative than than say a
building cycle or you think that that's
just the that's just the play that's
always going on and and you have to
figure out your role in it
well i think the play is always going on
there's like and i don't think like the
antidote to chaos isn't order and the
antidote to order isn't chaos the
antidote to both is the balancing right
the active balancing of them
you used to do this a lot you would say
the the balance the struggle between
liberal and conservatives so people see
me doing this all the time i was
credible jordan was talking about he was
talking about this but so you think
that's it well it's really important
it's really important to understand that
that the
that the antidote to chaos in the final
analysis can't just be ordered because
order itself can degenerate
and so
i believe that the antidote is active
engagement with the world honest active
engagement with the world truth and i
think it's also truth motivated by love
which is a motif that runs through this
second book in particular and love is
the desire for all things to flourish
you know in in in christ says that you
should love your enemies and that that's
an ins that what does that mean and and
it's really worth thinking about is you
shouldn't wish your enemies harm in this
like
and by by and i what i mean by that is
that it would be better for everyone if
they would conduct themselves so that
they would flourish
you know and that doesn't mean you
shouldn't defend yourself it doesn't
mean that that soldiers aren't necessary
or the police it doesn't mean any of
that it's not a weak need statement it
means that if you're if you have your
if you have your
if you have yourself pointed in the
right direction
you don't wish
an excess of harm on on the world you
want it to flourish that's love so you
aren't yourself
that way and i do believe that that
requires a certain courage because
the world is so flawed and so painful
there's so much suffering in it it's
very difficult to fall in love with it
you keep getting bounced off you think
this is so terrible that maybe it
shouldn't even be
but that takes you down a very bad road
so it's love first and then truth serves
that
and i do think that's the motif that
runs through the old and new testaments
that the combination of those two things
love is the
the desire that being flourish
and
and i do believe that truth serves that
well that's it
no please finish your thought
well i also think that people find
meaning in that
and you can everyone can answer this for
themselves it's like you have to watch
and you have to see where it is that you
find the meaning that sustains your life
and i would say it's certainly not been
my experience that people find that in
deceit or hatred
i mean they may be tempted by that they
may have the reasons for it
but everyone is ashamed of that
and wishes it could be otherwise
even if they don't know what to do about
that